[Music]
i have no name for this caller
we could workshop a name together okay
here we go
so this started almost at the stroke of
midnight last night
all right let's take a listen to the
first one this is a new caller we've
never had this one before
new caller
[Music]
once again i'm going to say it again now
have evidence
that one of the voting machines
in one of the counties in georgia did
flip
the vote oh
[Music]
you keep saying that
[Music]
once again we have evidence
now we can whimper we can whine
or we can fight we'll fight we'll fight
to fight fight
fighting fight fighting hard fight
fighting
[Music]
and then there's the fight
[Music]
[Music]
fighting
[Music]
next it is trump talking about massive
dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song
please do it
massive dumps
[Music]
dumps dumps dumps
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
donald trump multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election
which is just dumps
dumps
[Music]
tremendous amounts of water where the
water rushes out to sea
[Music]
dumps
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
[Music]
what is going on here what is going on
all right welcome everybody uh jen saki
the white house press secretary for joe
biden
is going to be briefing us shortly we
got a number of interesting statements
yesterday not all necessarily as
uh full and complete and
comprehensive as many of us would have
wanted
but uh at least they were discussions of
policy very very different than when
kaylee
mcinanni was press secretary she
reappeared on fox news
this morning welcomed on to the network
i guess she now works for fox news
so we're going to have a little bit of
that
interview or appearance momentarily
um i actually have a lot of different
things to go over
today uh we will get to super chats
although we don't have any
right now um and i have a voicemail to
play that i think will be very relevant
to our discussion we will debate whether
i am a person of color
um you'll understand more momentarily
we will look at covet cases we will look
at vaccinations oh and speaking of
vaccinations
we had a beautiful beautiful three-day
period over the weekend look at these
numbers
2.17 million doses on friday
2.35 million doses on saturday
2.42 million doses on sunday
only 1.6 million yesterday but that's
okay these are this is 6.9 million in
three days which is amazing
and with the approval of the third
vaccine the jnj
vaccine um and reportedly just
insane quantities of uh doses going out
in march
i am optimistic that we're going to be
in a much better place on vaccination
very very soon um
freddie says my power is out but i would
never miss your stream
appreciate that freddy great to see you
hope that uh power comes back on soon
no unban requests today i just don't
have any uh any unban requests to
adjudicate
uh the queue is completely clean clean
cue
even though i actually banned someone um
right before coming on i saw someone
with a bandworthy
uh with a bandworthy comment
a user going by troy york says that our
voicemail is not working
voicemail's working fine um
multiple voicemails over the last few
minutes
but i'm not playing troy york voicemails
because they've become
boring and pedantic that's it
okay all right let's discuss whether i'm
a person of color
check this out um many of you saw
the great netflix series queen's gambit
the lead actress is anya taylor joy who
like me
is argentinian um and like me
has uh european origin parents i believe
her
one of her parents is british or british
as we say um another one of her parents
is spanish
okay now i consider myself
latino and hispanic but i recognize
that you know as someone who's
ethnically ashkenazi jewish
and speaks english without an accent and
looks the way i look my my experience in
the us
has not been the experience of a brown
person
there's this article which says
argentinian taylor joy
is the first woman of color to win this
category since queen latifah in 2008.
i don't pretend to have an answer
all i know is that if she's a woman of
color
i'm a man of color and i these are
difficult things
and and you know you can end up really
in the weeds
again i i feel strongly that i'm
hispanic
i feel strongly that i'm latino based on
culture based on my first language being
spanish based on
you know being born in argentina being
an immigrant to the u.s
but am i a person of color is that my
experience i don't know
and i don't care to give or i'm not
looking to adjudicate
people being people of color i i just
it's just
unusual um and i i know what people are
saying
being latino or hispanic is not based on
color that's absolutely right and in
fact
ethnically i'm ashkenazi jewish
ethnically
has nothing it be me being latino and
hispanic has nothing to do with my color
i just don't know i've never seen that
term applied like i i definitely don't
feel like i'm a person of color
um
it's a nubilis term i think you mean
nebulous
yeah i don't know anyway so that's
that's interesting anya taylor joy
uh like me argentinian identified as the
first woman of color to win something i
don't know
i don't know you you make of it what you
will i do think it's interesting
um we'll continue to follow it
follow it and see if we get anything
noteworthy out of it
constance says i wish biden would
legalize weed well first he should
decriminalize
don't expect legalization before decrim
luke says how do i convince conservative
relatives that the biden democratic
party isn't socialism well first of all
ask them what
socialism is
pepe xanadu wants to know if i'm 155
pounds soaking wet
i'm getting a cringy creepy a vibe from
that super chat
i don't know it's a little weird not
gonna not gonna go into that
big thank you to justin spanbauer
for signing up at joinpackman.com and
thanks to
auntie picarinen for signing up at
joinpakman.com
new members 1 and 2 today also want to
say thanks to cactus matt
and dan's news for signing up via twitch
uh putting us at four okay
i have a voicemail to play for you guys
i find this funny
because i i i'm understanding some
people do
this is really instructive for me i
guess a lot of people don't get that
sometimes when i mispronounce things
it's a joke and uh
take a listen to this right here okay
david you have got to stop
[ __ ] like pronouncing things in a
weird way
because people are trolling you online
about how to [ __ ] pronounce [ __ ]
okay i don't need you to say ruby julie
annie
i [ __ ] know what you're talking about
you're talking about giuliani
you're getting caught up in the [ __ ]
trolls that are like
oh you don't see it that way you say it
this way guys
they're not tricking me i've tricked
them
just like you like you're making
yourself sound
really stupid i know you're an
intelligent guy you have a great show i
love your show
okay but you need to stop [ __ ]
like trying to pronounce [ __ ] to appease
these [ __ ] trolls
no no no no no it's the trolls that are
the confused ones
i know the right way to pronounce the
stuff and purists okay
just stop doing that [ __ ] you have an
awesome show
i love i actually so this is the
background on the mispronunciation
sam cedar from the majority report okay
so we did pronunciation i can get rid of
that
sam cedar from the majority report told
me
that back when he was on air america
radio he would sometimes sort of like
you know we're doing a show every day
and you look for things to entertain
yourself it's sort of like when
bands will riff on a song because you
play this if you play the hits every
night you'll start riffing on it
you know for yourself um sam cedar told
me
that when he was on air america radio he
started pronouncing the name of i
believe it's tennessee senator
former senator bill frist as bill freist
okay there was really no reason for it
but then he caught wind
i don't want to say who it was but a
pretty major media person
was apparently asking everybody why is
sam cedar
saying bill freist instead of bill frist
and sam was like that's why i'm doing it
that's exactly why because it's funny
that now this major media person is
going around saying
why is this radio host saying bill
freist instead of bill frist
okay that's all it is it's not
you know it's not hot super uh like high
uh sophisticated humor
it's just fun and also because i'm
picking ones that will trigger people
so like saying tulsi gabbard
tulsi has such a cult of personality
around her
where like if i just said you know uh i
don't know like if i said bernie sanders
i don't know that the cult of
personality around bernie is such that i
would have like a million emails saying
oh
with tulsi the people because of the
people that follow tulsi they're so
triggered by it
jimmy dore i know it's jimmy dore
it's because of the people that follow
jimmy dore are going to be insanely
triggered by hearing jimmy dore
when you know sometimes people will
email you saying david it's not
pronounced tulsa oklahoma
i know it's just a joke on tool c which
is a joke on tulsi
that's all it is okay
um i don't know what other ones there
are
there's some other k when i say kaylee
mcana a nanny
i know that that's not how cheap you
know i get emails from people saying
david because i'm
irish i can explain to you how to
properly pronounce come on guys
come on okay big thank you to john jay
carlos pakman
i love that for subscribing with twitch
prime love it
love it also thank you to simon zipecki
or rippecki i don't know if the r is
silent or the z
is silent simon ripecki for signing up
at joinpakman.com so that's
six from the standpoint of
uh sign ups there okay wait a second no
and i need to keep a note
all right so that's it on pronunciation
that's it on pronunciation
how many tier three twitch subscribers
do i have only two
only two tier three subscribers
currently on twitch all right i know
it's sad i know
all right a few other super chats here i
can't stand
argentinian taylor joy and i can't
believe those kids in georgia elected
her
nice nice when when jen picks on a
reporter for questions can we elect
officially say they are being being sack
tapped
wow my 79 year old granny with a litany
of health issues got a second shot arms
sore no other issues not a zombie bill
gates isn't peeking into our windows
did you have another career path in mind
before pursuing current career
no i mean i always believed
entrepreneurship would be my path
and it was i just didn't necessarily
know it would be
media entrepreneurship would it be worth
it to focus on mental health treatment
as a way to deprogram people on the
right
yes in fact i talked about that
yesterday
i talked about that yesterday uveon says
david i think trump republicans are a
joke as much as the next guy but i do
think the transport issue is a real
issue regardless of party
it's a real issue in a limited sense and
i've already addressed that
and actually today i have i have a long
segment on cancel culture
cancel culture the new obsession uh for
many
look at some of these clips this is this
is the obsession now
cancel culture why they have no policy
they're losing on cultural issues
they're losing the elections they're
losing everything so now it's cancelled
culture
there's this cancel culture trying to
cancel dr seuss now
right how far are they going to take
this
uh okay there's no place that they won't
go
uh ainsley there's no place they won't
go this week alone
they canceled mr potato head you know
this week alone they canceled the
muppets
uh what a defiant and principled speech
here by don jr
uh you know they're they're canceling dr
seuss from reading programs i mean these
are books
i literally know the cat and the hat by
heart without the book there because i
read it so many times
to my children these things are not
racist you have oreo cookie chiming in
on trans rights
i mean what is going on i have no this
is the obsession
uh then an extra monologue from ainslie
earhart this morning
it is march 2nd it is read across
america day
it is also dr seuss's birthday and
traditionally in our country we
celebrate read across america on his
birthday because right
we all literature is a major issue you
you know that this is bs you know that
this is all fabricated
because the fox news audience is not
exactly uh
they're not exactly following the pulse
of literature
so anytime literature is a topic on fox
news
you know that it's some kind of
concocted issue grew up reading his
books and loved them
but uh biden is there is a proclamation
claiming that this
is read across america day but he is
leaving out the mention
of dr seuss because of this one county
loudoun county in virginia
and they are saying that it's
controversial
and they want to cancel dr seuss jim
jordan calling for congressional
hearings on cancel culture
here's a woman on tucker's show look at
how confused tucker looks right here
hold on where was it right here look at
how confused he looks
um this was a guest on tucker's show
saying women are being canceled army i
appreciate you're coming on tonight
so the equality act everything is orwell
um
is this is this about equality
uh it would better be named the women's
cancellation act because it looks like
cancel culture has finally come
for the female uh gender tucker what
we're seeing in this act is basically a
denial of science and this is the flat
earthers
taking control of the government and
using those levers of power
to elevate the rights of transgender
uh women met people who are born as men
over the rights of biological women
and it's not just conservatives who are
concerned about this tucker it is all no
no no it's not
okay so anyway cancel culture we'll have
a i've got a big segment on today's show
about that
all right um i do have one unban request
to adjudicate i've got to just reach for
my gavel excuse me
here it is all right i have one unban
request via twitch to adjudicate
um
oh you know what oh i see what's going
on i'm not even going to say the user's
name
so there's a user who just said love the
channel dad and they were banned and i
was looking at that and i was like why
were there bad they banned
their username is disgustingly
anti-semitic so that's a perma-ban
um and that is just adjudicated and i
don't even i'm not even gonna say the
name because that i can tell that that's
what they would get pleasure from nicely
caught by the way green man nice job our
moderator green man
was not gonna fall for that that is
insta perma
that's just never again very good okay
next thing uh oh uh thanks to liam
stericker liam stericker just grabbed a
membership at joinedpakman.com
i would love it if you signed up at
joinpackman.com also
thanks to augusto colts for signing up
via twitch um and in fact that's uh
there we go puts us at eight for the day
the coupon code is working the coupon
code
is working better 21 working perfectly
okay
our a friend of ours greg did something
really funny
okay remember that completely abortive
um national anthem performance from cpac
over the weekend
greg went in and he retuned it so it
sounds
good so i have for you what that
national anthem performance could have
sounded like
this is so brilliant now here's my
question should i play the real one
first or should i play the fixed
one first i don't know which would be
funnier to play first
like should i just be like like this is
what it could have been but then here's
what it really sounded like is that
funny
real then fixed
okay people want the real one first fair
all right so this is the real national
anthem from um
from the the cpac thing
[Music]
the twilight's last gleaming
whose brought stripes and
bright stars
through the peril
[Applause]
[Music]
were so gallantly streaming
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of the freest
[Applause]
and
[Music]
okay anyway so here's the tuned version
like and this actually it sounds almost
perfect
this is great from
[Music]
what greg's proudly we
hailed at the twilight's
last gleaming
whose broad stripes and
bright stars
through the peril last
fight all the
ramparts we
[Music]
much better
[Music]
yet
[Music]
okay anyway so sounding much better
there thanks to thanks to technology but
really
uh just you know they should have picked
somebody else as the truth i'm sure
she's a really really nice girl and
everything but
um it was it was uh you know if
democrats did that at their conference
if at net roots nation
they democrats do that uh the right says
that's
you know disrespectful uh that type of
thing
all right other super chats coming in
one page of trump's book i wish biden
would use appropriately is visiting
parts of the country in person well
we're in a pandemic let's wait till
we're out of the pandemic to evaluate
that
um now that i am fully vaccinated do i
plan to do anything different
yes i just don't know what i just don't
know what but absolutely
tips on how to approach a friend who's
deep in the jordan peterson cult that i
don't know
that i don't know i i've not figured out
how to deal with that
don jr the top person to talk about
muppetry
that's good interesting to see
conservatives melt down over cancel
culture when a few years ago they were
burning nikes because of colin
kaepernick yeah i know
they're they're hypocrites neither are
nor z
is silent in polish we pronounce rz as
one sound
oh my god i don't know that my brain can
do that
how do you how is rz1 sound
i believe you i just i don't think my
mouth can do it
i'm already signed up on the website but
thanks for letting me know kidding aside
thanks for the live shows david thank
you
you're doing great work says zachary did
you know dave rubin attaches a cinder
block to a zip line
and runs it into his head hoping to
replace one with the other i didn't know
that
i didn't know that um there were at
least 12 key changes there yeah
whoever had that poor girl singing
should be voted out definitely
definitely has she never heard the og
version ted cruz attended harvard so
he's smart right
hoping for a better 21 when david can
get through a live stream without being
told his coupon code isn't working
wishing you the best yes thank you the
anthem was appropriate for cpac a
bastardization
of our national song for the
bastardization of the country's
conservative movement
in a sense it was poetically appropriate
that's true
what's the best response to the sicilian
defense of flipping the board over and
walking out
maybe she's a great singer and decided
to embellish the song
with random modulations and key changes
maybe maybe
um kaylee mcinanny yeah i have a kaylee
mac in it guys you know
you know now i don't know if i am being
trolled
the coupon code is working liam
just used the coupon code simon just
used the coupon code auntie didn't but
that was by choice
and justin used the coupon code the
koopa it it's not a case sensitivity
issue
all caps works all lower case works
uh you know un alternating capital and
lowercase works
it's all it's all happening okay all
right very good
let's get to kaylee mcinanny i guess now
she works for
fox news this was this morning we
started with how she was treated in the
press room
and what she is seeing now with the
biden team
i would say um
disparate unfair in the sense of
a rep and i said this to my staff often
often a
democrat woman uh standing at that
podium
would never have had a playboy reporter
in the back of the room shouting at her
as she left and
nor should a democrat woman ever have to
face that and nor should a republican
woman there's a certain modicum of
respect
that i think reporters uh see the
problem with this
is it starts from the premise that her
press briefings
and the sake press briefings are the
same it starts
with that as the idea and by the way we
want to make sure we don't miss the
press briefing when it starts
she didn't answer questions uh she
attacked the people in the room yeah
there was there's you can't compare
anything
if you're starting with completely
different situations
and those at the podium in a political
role should have for one another and
there are
some incredible reporters who to this
day represent the kind of journalism i
think is good but
it was very clear i think we don't need
to name names but i think the audience
will be well aware of some of the
uh reporters who were more interested in
uh
being uh you know political operatives
let's say
than journalists and i think they made
themselves known i don't want to put you
on the spot with jinsaki
the white house press secretary for the
biden administration
so maybe this is a better way to ask it
rather than what grade would you give
her
um how is her job different by the way
she is treated
than you because everyone just asks
softball questions and papa
that you were treated i think that's
fair yeah that's uh that's a that's a
great question i mean look first i wish
her all the best i left her notes
saying that much uh we've had we've met
previously one time and she was very
kind
and so were some of her colleagues that
in the press shop
and i left her note i wish her the best
but it's different
in a big way i'll never forget watching
one of the early press briefings and she
was asked about the antifa riots and
i believe she said that she hadn't
spoken to the president about that and
they let her move on whereas if i would
have been asked that about
you know violence um on the other side
of the aisle
um that wouldn't have been an answer
that's completely untrue kaylee
regularly got away with
i don't have anything for you on that i
don't uh you know i'm not sure i haven't
spoken to the president about that i'm
not going to telegraph or predict what
it is that the president
that is such bs such such bs
and um anyway so now she was welcomed i
guess
i guess kaylee now works for um
works for fox news which we reported was
in the works
but then was delayed i guess because it
just looked very bad in the aftermath of
the january sixth riots
and now now she was welcomed to the fox
news family this morning so
who the hell knows okay
other super chats coming in
does it seem like biden can pass an
immigration plan i've seen articles that
say he can with republicans can he do
health care with reconciliation
these are all different questions um
biden you know immigration plan there's
a few different components one is what
can he do about deportations
which in theory he can do via executive
order although his initial attempt was
blocked by a judge
then there's can he fix daca i actually
do think he can deal with daca with
republicans
and then when it comes to doing health
care with reconciliation i don't believe
so
uh but i would love to be proven wrong
bae photo says faulk this interview
why do politicians still act like high
schoolers
i don't know i don't know pepe but
there's probably
quite a bit to that psychologically
uh oh i think things are starting oh
this is very very soon
i want to say thanks to derek quinn who
just signed up via joinpakman.com
also matzo ball soup love it one of the
best soups
just signed up via joinpakman.com very
much appreciate that
also thanks to web shooter j.s feder
federer paula 2 for signing up via
twitch
and a few other people as well in fact
10
putting us at 20. do i have any
non-weaponized voicemails let's see we
actually
might have something from the eggman let
me take a quick look
um did i have an eggman voicemail
oh maybe not no i guess i don't i
thought i had something from the eggman
hold on a second here
uh let me see if i can find something
just like a quote normal voicemail
okay no that's not good
when i get past let's see i want to give
some people
okay let's listen to this one's about
vaccines let's listen to this
hi david i have some things to say about
your another
anti-vaxxer comes back for more
clip on youtube today so the first thing
um i i really objected to when you said
that the person was nuts bad
liar or mentally ill and the reason i
objected to that is because you're
putting
in mental illness so i
unfortunately the caller we i got a call
from someone saying
is a lot of conspiracism just mental
illness and i said
some of it probably is let's listen okay
i have quite a few things at the top
lots of news happening here at the white
house
today in our kova teams weekly meeting
with the governors
we announced another supply increase for
states tribes and territories
from 14.5 to 15.2 million doses per week
love it this is up from 8.6 million when
we came into office
furthermore states are also receiving
2.8 million of the johnson and johnson
vaccine this week
so they're receiving a total of 18
million doses
wow later today president biden will
deliver remarks on the status of our
covid19 response
and he will announce unprecedented
historic step
the two largest healthcare and
pharmaceutical companies
merck and johnson and johnson usually
competitors
are coming together to expand production
of the vaccine
johnson johnson's vaccine drugs drug
substance as well as increase
its fill finish capacity they will
they will answer in it to a historic
manufacturing partnership to expand that
i should say
the us government will facilitate this
partnership in several key ways
including invoking the defense
production act to equip
two merc facilities to the standards
necessary
to safely manufacture the vaccine and
asking the department of defense to
provide
the daily logistical support to
strengthen johnson and johnson's
efforts great news we'll have more to
say on that later this afternoon
to pump up the vaccine also today the
biden harris administration is
announcing
key conclusions from an intelligence
community assessment on the poisoning of
alexi navalny
as well as measures to hold russia
accountable for this
action the intelligence community
assesses with high confidence
that officers of russia's federal
security service used a nerve agent to
poison russian
opposition leader alexei navalny on
august 20th 2020.
the use of any chemical weapon directly
violates international legal obligations
and norms of civilized conduct
and our actions today fall into a number
of categories and reflect a whole of
government
response we are also working with
congress to ensure we are faithfully
implementing the chemical and biological
weapons
act today the united states is
announcing sanctions on seven
senior members of the russian government
an expansion of sanctions under the
chemical and biological weapons control
and warfare elimination act
new export restrictions on items that
could be used for biological
agent and chemical production and visa
restrictions
and the department of states commerce
and treasury will also have releases out
shortly with further
details as a demonstration of our
transatlantic unity and
cooperation with partners uh over the
ocean
many of the actions we are taking mirror
the steps the eu took in october and
match additional eu measures
uh being taken today we also reiterate
our call for the russian government to
immediately and unconditionally
release mr navalny a lot of talk uh i
know you're all interested in what we're
doing on the american rescue plan and
how we're engaging with members of
congress so i have an update for all of
you
president biden and his team continue to
engage closely with congressional
leadership
and members of the uh uh and with
members
about the american rescue plan including
with republicans
yesterday the president met with a group
of nine democratic senators and today
he's meeting with the full
senate democratic caucus for their
weekly lunch
in the past two weeks alone we've
engaged with over 350
75 members and offices over a hundred of
which were bipartisan
engagements and our kova team is also
started by weekly bipartisan member
briefings
with the senate and house where of
course we talk about the american rescue
plan and the impact
it can have um i have one other item i
actually had an item on the travel of
the first lady and i will venture to get
that to all of you after the briefing so
with that
zeke kick it off uh first on this uh j j
deal what role does the president or the
white house have in making this
partnership happen
the details but how did these two
companies come together
well as i noted in the opening uh these
obviously are two companies that are
historically been
competitors uh so the fact that they are
coming together speaks to
the ability of this administration
broadly to bring them to the table
and work together to address the
pandemic in the country
it was an across the administration
effort i'm not going to detail
exactly which individual was in in
charge of each component
other than to say that when the
president came into office
and as soon as we learned about the fact
that that
johnson and johnson was behind in the
manufacturing
steps and efforts we took steps to
ensure we could expedite that
and partner them with the one of the
world's biggest manufacturers
is is the administration doing this
because j j needs this
production capacity from merck to meet
its uh commitments the federal
government for 100 million doses by the
end of juniors a separate
from that well certainly our objective
is to build on the incredible
announcement that we now have three
vaccines that the american people can
have access to
can can use to vaccinate them from
and protect them from the virus and we
knew we learned early on that they were
not early on but in the recent days it's
all relative uh that they were behind on
their manufacturing
capacity and so we took steps uh to
ensure
we could capitalize on the scientific
breakthrough
that this was necessary for the company
to meet its commitments to the federal
government
i i wouldn't put in those terms zeke i
would just say that it was a step
that helps uh ensure that johnson and
johnson's vaccine can be
the production of it can be expedited
that the manufacturing of it can be
expedited and that's of course good news
for the american people
on vaccines um yesterday the topic of
events of sharing vaccines came up in
the present conversation with president
of mexico uh the president said he's
going to talk
about it in that in that conversation is
the president uh
open to flexibility in terms of sharing
these vaccines now with uh
long-time american allies and what is
the threshold at which the president
will share
start exporting some of these american
made vaccines overseas
well that's diplomacy in action right
there the president's been at it for a
long time
and uh but the president did not make
any commitments uh nor did he give a
time
yeah it's weird like biden said we're
gonna first make sure everybody here who
wants a vaccine can get one then we'll
look at sharing the vaccines it'll
probably be june july i don't i mean
it's weird to expect her to say
something more detailed the american
people but
there are a couple of factors that our
team looks at including the fact that we
don't know which vaccine will be most
effective
on children we don't know the impact of
variance still
under consideration and being looked at
by our health and medical experts
we are of course securing all of these
doses so we can plan for a range of
scenarios
we have contributed to kovacs which is
the international
coordinating body to help provide
assistance around
certainly when we get to the point where
the majority where we have
vaccinated the american public of course
we want the global community
to be vaccinated that makes us all safer
we've heard from the scientists
on some of these calls uh calling on
government not to roll back mass
mandates and other restrictions on
public gatherings some states are
in the process of rolling back some of
those very restrictions right now we've
not really heard from the president on
that
uh should be expected to hear from the
president has the president been
directly lobbying
governors and state officials against
rowling good question
these are private and then should we
expect to hear from him publicly going
forward encouraging american the
american people to follow
his guidelines but not their governors
well i i will say having traveled with
the president to texas on friday he made
clear that we need to be vigilant and
that's also what dr velensky
conveyed over the last several days it
may feel
a little bit better out there that's
good news if you go to the grocery store
there's more toilet paper on the shelves
there's
more clorox wipes on the shelves it's
getting warmer out there more people are
getting vaccinated
people feel better that's a good thing
but we need to remain vigilant
we are still at war with the virus the
president of course will continue to
convey that publicly
and also privately in his conversations
oh
let me see go ahead thank you dad um
just a couple questions on the uh on the
part partnership
um um did uh can we expect
and you know what is the timeline by
when we can expect the first vaccine to
roll off
of the lines of mercs facilities uh and
has merck started working
on this new vaccine already i would
expect there'll be more details from
the department of health and human
services on the contract and the
specifics later this afternoon after the
president's announcement
and you mentioned that you are that the
government has
or is willing to invoke the dpa can you
give us any more details on that
we we did invoke the dpa um in order to
alleviate two of the biggest bottlenecks
facing johnson and johnson
uh one is a fill finish capacity which
is actually kind of the bottle the top
that's put on these bottles of vaccines
and the other is drug substance
availability which is
some of the components that make up the
um the ingredients in the vaccine so
those were pieces that uh are steps we
invoke the dpa in order to implement
those particular pieces
but the other piece uh that we are
focused on here is ensuring that
the the um uh merck facilities are
uh up to capacity of what's needed to uh
to manufacture the johnson and johnson
vaccine
in the production here will that be used
uh
for use in the united states or is it
earmarked for global use
how will the vaccines be used once they
are um
well we've ordered or we have ordered a
set number about 100 million vaccines
there's a contract that was in
uh in process before these steps were
taken
um so that's what these actions will be
focused on one question on
on the covert rescue packaging does
president biden and the white house feel
any need
to perhaps reduce the unemployment
benefits in the bill
as you're aware of you know lawmakers
such as senator manchin
support a lower threshold
in many ways at 300 over 400 per week
what is your position on that well the
president obviously had a discussion
with a number of senators
just yesterday uh senator manchin was
certainly one of them and he's
long said that he would be open to
hearing ideas that make the bill
and the package stronger it's an ongoing
process but i don't have anything more
to read out in terms of their
conversation
go ahead on russia and the volume and
the sanctions that you just announced at
the top of this briefing
the biden administration didn't punish
mohammed bin salman directly for
um khashoggi's death you're not
punishing vladimir putin directly for
development's imprisonment
only those around them so how is that
going to deter
these leaders from good questions
good question well uh i would say first
that our national security team
uh as it relates to saudi arabia let me
let me take these pieces slightly
separately peter
um made a determination that i have a
different page for each piece
from the moment the president came into
office uh we were going to treat that
relationship
differently and we did not wait for the
release of this unclassified report
by the way it didn't have much
information you didn't know or nbc and
other outlets were not reporting
previously it confirmed what we have
long known uh that an innocent reporter
doing his job committed to telling the
truth was killed in a horrific crime
our objective is to recalibrate the
relationship
we took a number of steps including
releasing this report
including ceasing our support for
offensive operations in yemen
including ensuring engagement was
counterpart to counterpart
and also pushing for the release of u.s
citizens
and human rights activists who were
released we also took additional steps
last week which were determined by our
national security team were the right
steps
to deter and to change the behavior
moving forward
those included sanctioning the former
deputy head of general intelligence it
included
imposing visa restrictions on 76 saudi
individuals
it included designating the saudi rapid
intervention force which is
a crucial step because it structurally
addresses an unacceptable pattern of
targeted monitoring harassment and
threats to journalists and dissidents
and included the khashoggi rule and our
conversations with the saudis
at every level make clear that we expect
additional reforms to be put in place
that their behavior will change we've
seen some evidence of that but we will
continue to press on that moving forward
but ultimately this is on the back of
the new announcement as it relates to
russia right now so if you don't do
anything that directly touch
touches mbs or vladimir putin why do you
expect those leaders to
stop this behavior well again peter with
all due respect
this these decisions were made on the
basis of decades of experience
and consideration by our national
security team on what would be
most effective in not only deterring
actions like this in the future
preventing this from ever happening
again which is of course our objective
but also being able to maintain a
relationship moving forward and of
course we have important work
we do with the kingdom of saudi arabia
from intelligence sharing
uh to deterring uh the actions of
militants in the region
uh and those are in the national
interests of the united states let me
ask you about immigration if i can
yesterday you brought into the briefing
room the department of homeland security
secretary alejandro
mayorkas who said the following he said
we are not saying don't come to those
migrants he said
we are saying don't come now because
we'll be able to deliver
a safe and orderly process to them as
quickly as possible so the message was
don't come now it sounds like the
message is come later so when should
these migrants come
well as you know the president has put
forward an immigration
october third peter not only provide a
pathway to citizenship
but will help put in place uh smart
security measures at the border
we'll also address root causes in the
region there also
is time and he talked about this quite a
bit yesterday as you know
that we need to dig out from the immoral
and ineffective
approach to immigration of the last
administration that's going to take
time probably months uh for us to be
able to process people at the border
to get people on the right path for
consideration of uh
for asylum seekers and others now is not
the moment for that
it sounds like even if unintentionally
you're sending the message that these
migrants
can't come they just gotta wait a little
bit longer is that the message you're
sending
well we've been also clear as he was
yesterday the majority of people who
come to the border are turned away
even even undocumented uh even even kids
who come in
at the border unaccompanied minors who
come in and we have
emphasized time and time again we want
to keep them safe we want to treat them
with humanity
they are not guaranteed to stay in the
united states they still go through the
processing
we just don't want to send them back and
the consideration of whether they can
stay here
through uh what is a possible thing i
don't think this
is great and i don't think the biden uh
white house has really
like been coherently messaging on this
believe differently from the past
administration that we are not going to
turn away kids who are under 18.
is the president going to be briefed on
this from the domestic policy council
today dhs assessing 117
or so thousand thousand unaccompanied
children 117 000
unaccompanied children will arrive in
the u.s by their projection
this year will he learn about it today
and that number
seems like a crisis the secretary said
it isn't
how would we define a crisis well i'll
leave that to the secretary of homeland
security to define he said it was a
challenge it is a challenge uh
we have more than seven thousand uh uh
unaccompanied kids who have come
into the united states um and and that
is certainly a lot of children that we
are trying to treat humanely and safely
and and process through the system as
quickly as we can uh that's
that's not easy that is a challenge uh
certainly the president receives
briefings and regular updates from his
team
um and you know we typically don't
confirm those publicly but
he is he is briefed regularly by his
team the domestic policy council
and other members of his policy team
sure
go ahead thank you uh one additional
question on the timeline coming out of
this announcement you mentioned that jj
is set to deliver 100 million vaccines
by the end of june will this new
partnership help americans get these
shots
any sooner uh it should uh
it definitely will expedite uh the
efforts of the united states government
having enough vaccines on hand
to vaccinate the american public the
president will talk more about that and
give more specifics
later this afternoon when he provides
when he speaks to all of you
but certainly having three vaccines
approved by the fda
the fact that we have taken these
actions we have used the full power of
the federal government to expedite the
manufacturing
that certainly should expedite the
process and should make vaccines more
readily available to americans
and one question on the first lady you
mentioned her travel she is set tomorrow
to go out and
tour some schools with the new education
secretary wondering if you have any
additional preview on this i think she's
visiting two schools that have found a
way
to reopen will she be speaking to some
of the challenges that communities
across the country are facing
now as they deal with this she will be
she'll be traveling that's what i was
intending to to provide more detail on
at the top
i must have moved the paper out of my
out of my binder here but
she will be traveling with the secretary
of education who has just confirmed as
you all know
they will be having a conversation with
uh at these schools that they're
visiting that have reopened about what
has been effective what has worked
uh what are the lessons learned what do
they need more assistance with
uh and certainly that is information
that they will
take back with them after these visits
they're doing tomorrow that secretary
cardona
his number one priority is reopening
schools and so certainly
taking a trip with the first lady is an
indication of his commitment to that
go ahead thanks jen a question about
governor andrew cuomo
vice president kamala harris was one of
the most vocal critics of justice brett
kavanaugh
of senator al franken when they faced
similar allegations
she said repeatedly i believe them
the women but she hasn't said anything
about the three women who are accusing
governor
andrew cuomo and now this third accuser
anna rouche
she actually worked for the biden harris
campaign so at what point
is the first female vice president going
to say something about this
well i i know that's how the the vice
president continues to feel and
uh the benefit of doing a briefing every
day is that i can certainly speak on
behalf of the president and the vice
president and so let me reiterate that
they both believe that every woman
coming forward should be heard
should be treated with dignity and
treated with respect
as you all know the new york attorney
general will oversee an independent
investigation
with subpoena power and the governor's
office said he will fully cooperate and
we certainly
support that moving forward but as you
know it's one thing to hear it
from you and it's appreciated but it's
another thing to hear it
from the vice president or the president
himself can we expect to hear from
either of them on this topic anytime
soon
well again i'm speaking on their behalf
that's how they feel
uh they're personally both view this as
a
situation where uh bo all of the women
coming forward
should be treated with dignity and
respect and should have their voices
heard
and that's uh the representation of
their points of view and one question on
immigration just to pick up from where
where peter left off
uh you know i know you have said that
you don't want to label this a crisis
secretary murphis was in here yesterday
saying it's not a crisis but now you
have
axios reporting that the administration
needs 20 000 beds
to shelter these children based on our
own reporting 97
of the beds through the office of
refugee resettlement are full so
i don't want to sound like a broken
record here but at what point
does it become a crisis well i would say
i don't think we need to meet your bar
of what we need to call it
we had the secretary of homeland
security yesterday conveying it's a
challenge
we've provided numbers publicly about
how serious that challenge is
uh we of course because we are
approaching this humanely
and we are approaching this in a way
where we will keep the children safe and
in a great break with the past
administration and because we're doing
this at a time of covid
that is even more challenging because
most of these facilities are at 40
capacity hence the number of beds that
are being uh
being uh utilized um but again uh we're
going to approach this
without labeling we're going to approach
this with policy
with humanity uh and with uh a focus on
what we can do to keep these kids safe
uh and keep them and keep get them in
homes as quickly as possible
go ahead um okay the stuff on the crisis
terminology seems like just trying to
get a headline
it talks with any other uh vaccine
manufacturers to pick up either on the
johnson johnson vaccine or
pfizer or madrana to get more doses out
right now
i i don't think we have anything to
preview for that on that for you
i will say that the manufacturing
process for pfizer and moderna
does not allow for smooth transfer from
one manufacturer to
another in the same capacity so this was
a step taken
because the johnson johnson vaccine is a
more traditional vaccine
and it merks experience manufacturing
other other vaccines will allow it to
scale and effectively produce the
johnson and johnson vaccine and then i
wanted to follow on a question you got
yesterday about the johnson johnson
vaccine
you you explained that it was being
distributed by population
state to state but there's a i guess a
question of
whether it might not make more sense you
know to
distribute more of the johnson johnson
vaccine to more rural states where they
might not have the capacity for the
where it might be tougher to ship
something that needs to be stored at an
extremely cold temperature
where they might only have you know
centralized hospitals and you should not
be able to distribute that and so i'm
wondering if you could explain the
administration's strategy of
why johnson johnson isn't being sent out
to places where it might logistically
make more sense
you could balance it out by maybe having
more flies or madonna and
like so it's a good question you know
it's easy to get from one side of the
the not the first time those are all
important considerations
but what uh the clear advice from our
health and medical team is and they've
looked closely at all of the questions
you've raised all important ones
is that if you have access for the
american people if you have whatever
vaccine you have access to
you should take that vaccine and of
course uh all of these vaccines
really enable it in communities across
the country as we've talked about a
little bit here we're going to have
more than enough vaccine doses to
distribute to
communities across the country yeah they
keep saying i think it's fair though
like you can figure out in
in in different states you might say in
this state
people are on average five miles from a
hospital versus two miles
you might say in the state where it's
five miles let's do more j and j since
it's one dose it only requires one trip
that that's totally legit
i don't i'm not super satisfied with the
answer center at the mass vaccination
site
eventually there will be enough vaccines
for everybody but what about right now
gotten some questions on this
but again the chief of staff beginning
the administration had promised a sort
of central clearinghouse
phone internet for for vaccine
information and you've kind of
pointed to this effort where
you can go on vaccine finder yes yeah
well i guess this is my question
do you do you find that to be sufficient
because i think what we're hearing a lot
from americans is that it's
you know americans who want to take get
this vaccine is
it's extremely hard to navigate yeah
appointment it's it's not really
functioning and
one promise of your administration was
we're going to federalize this we're
going to
be a central clearinghouse we're going
to kind of
step in and help what has been scatter
shots you're right and and the vaccine
finder
website is available in about a half a
dozen states there are also
websites in many states that provide
access
and provide guideline or guidance
looking for where they can get a vaccine
and access so that is true in different
states across the country as well
but one of the things we've also found
and the prism at which we're looking at
this through
is that it's not just about people being
able to go on websites
people also don't all have access to the
internet including many people who
are in communities where there's higher
level vaccine hesitancy or rural
communities
and so we've also taken a number of
steps call centers
proactive outreach to communities from
health centers
to get people to come and take the
vaccine because a website is not going
to be the silver bullet that solves
everything
it's a pilot and so our intention is to
expand it but it's not going to be the
only thing that helps solve this for the
public
uh go ahead um two questions
follow up on the vaccine and then a
navalny question
um on the timing of of the
administration's efforts
to help pull this deal together you said
that it was within
i think the last few weeks is that what
you had said
we wrote our first story at the new york
times about a possible partnership
between merck
and j j for manufacturing on january
21st
that was when it published so and my
understanding i think talks between
those companies have been in
in the works before that even in terms
of
sort of the corporate discussions
between them so i mean
could you help explain how it is that
the biden administration deserves credit
for bringing these two together when
it looks like the discussions had been
under way long before you guys got here
well my just to be clear i'm talking
about when it was finalized so that we
could move it forward
um of course there are conversations
between companies um
but in terms of getting it to a point
and obviously the johnson and johnson
vaccine was only approved
last weekend right and we were waiting
on the fda
to make the final approvals of the
vaccine
but uh there's a difference between
conversations and it moving forward
and the use of the defense protection
this is all kind of lame like yeah
they're gonna try to overtake credit and
then you know trump's going to continue
trying to take
okay and also uh the commitment to help
upgrade the manual or help
get the manufacturing facilities to the
place where they needed to be in order
to produce the vaccine
so uh i'm only conveying what got it
across the finish line and i think it's
clear
that that has only happened uh
relatively recently but
certainly the history of conversations
between
merck and j and j long before the j j
vaccine was even approved
you know you certainly might have more
information on than i do second
question on the timing of all of this um
it's our understanding that the the
time that it's going to take merck to
spin up the production
of any kind of either the fit and
the finish and then also the production
of the vaccine itself
is months from now i mean the the phrase
fourth quarter has been has been talked
about
which would would seem to undercut your
assertion i think uh
to a couple of questions earlier that
that this partnership in particular is
going to have
any benefit now that's a good question
the
100 million dose pledge right i mean if
if your hundred hundred million does
pledges by
uh by the end of july and merck's
production isn't going to get started
until you know september october
november
the commitment the contract is by the
end of june but i expect the president
will have more to say this afternoon on
the impact on the timeline
and then one question on the navalny
and russia sanctions
you know the the russia was sanctioned
in very much the same way in the wake of
the previous poisoning
um that that was attributed that was
attributed to
putin and the russian government and
you know those sanctions essentially
were ignored right i mean we now have
the navalny poisoning that came
despite the sort of series of similar
sanctions that were imposed so i guess
the question is
and i think the previous poisoning but
what is it that makes
the gives your national security team a
level of confidence that
some different outcome is going to
happen from essentially doing the same
thing that was done before i mean is
there some
is there something that we all don't
know about why
this is going to be effective these
limited steps when essentially they
weren't effective before
well first the announcement we're making
today was done
in harmony with the eu announcement it
was not meant to be
a silver bullet or an ending to
what has been a difficult relationship
with russia we expect the relationship
to continue to be a challenge
we're prepared for that and we're
neither seeking to reset our relations
with russia nor are we seeking to
escalate there's also an ongoing process
as you know
uh with uh to consider a number of steps
of concerning behavior taken by
the russians that is still ongoing and
we
made this announcement because we wanted
to do it in a timeline
aligned with the european union which
sends does send a powerful message
but we're not naive about the challenge
we continue to believe it's a it's a
challenging relationship
uh the uh the president made that clear
and made clear what our focus is when he
spoke with president putin
and that review was ongoing and we of
course
reserve the right to take additional
steps and take taken additional actions
at the conclusion
is that essentially a concession that
that you recognize that the steps taken
today
are not likely to prevent further
attempted assassinations by the
by putin or the
no i appreciate the option i'm certainly
not making that concession
i'm conveying that it was taken today
in order to be in uh in the same
timeline as the european union
there is an ongoing review there we
reserve the right to take any additional
actions at the conclusion of that review
and just reiterating that the tone and
the tenor
and the type of relationship that this
president intends to have with president
putin will be
quite different from the last
administration go ahead
jen sort of following up on that you had
mentioned
uh also being able to maintain a
relationship moving forward with russia
despite the sanctions what specific
areas
are are you considering such as iran
syria the start talks can you be a
little
specific well we of course
we already signed the extension on new
start a couple of weeks ago that is a
good example
and that is an example of where
engagement is in the interests of the
united states and
in our national security interests there
are also areas some of which you touched
on
of course depending on where things land
with the invitation for diplomatic talks
on iran
russia is a p5 plus one partner they
were as we pursued the jcpoa under the
obama biden administration they
certainly would be a key
uh a key partner if that diplomatic
process were to move forward so
the point is there are areas where we
disagree there are areas where there's
significant challenge
there are also areas where we are going
to work with the russians as we would
with most global partners
uh in in when we need to take steps that
are in interest of the united states
just one more if i may some unfinished
business with uh democratic party
lawmakers who are still peeved about
this lack of
congressional notification senator tim
kaine
says i learned about it on the news and
he's a member of the armed services and
foreign relations committee
he says i don't think i should be
learning about it this way what what
what do you say to
senator kaine and others who are upset
on the hill
well i know that statement was from a
couple of days ago
i would say that there were
notifications done
of committee chairs i don't have any
more specifics on that there was also
additional notifications and
conversations that happened on friday
and we've
made an offer of classified briefings
for anyone who
would meet that bar senator kane is a
important uh important important partner
for this administration he's somebody
the president has known for quite some
time and
we look forward to continuing to work
with him on a range of issues
go ahead thank you thank you either we
we're not going anywhere go ahead okay
um we're seeing
a couple questions on kovic we're seeing
reports uh
out of kansas and missouri that small
rural areas are receiving large
quantities of doses
and that uh larger urban areas are
receiving smaller
shipments of doses relative to their
populations
and so i'm wondering if the white house
is satisfied that local
state and local governments are doing
what they need to do
in terms of ensuring vaccine equity well
we certainly
track um when we see if there it for
example
if there were one of the vaccines that
were distributed primarily into certain
demographic communities or neighborhoods
that would be a concern to us as well
we tracked that closely i'm not familiar
with these specific issues but it is
something that
our cova team looks at and as their
issues they raise them directly with
state leaders on um on mobile
vaccination sites
i'm wondering what the federal rule is
and if the
federal government is helping to select
the sites that these mobile
sites are gone we are working in close
as i noted a little bit earlier uh our
kova coordinator
chef science has a weekly meeting with
governors where
he provides an update they have a
discussion we're also involved
and engaged with local and state leaders
on a
regular basis and certainly mobile
vaccination sites
and the implementation of those and
where they can most effectively
be utilized is something that is part of
that discussion
i'm wondering what the administration is
doing to avoid some of the problems
that might arise with the jnj vaccine
that equate
the astrazeneca vaccine in europe where
in germany and france the estrozetic
vaccine seems to be treated as a
secondary vaccine or a
second choice because of the perception
that it has a lower efficacy rate is
there a concern
that that might might be an issue with
bj
well one of the reasons that we've been
very clear and why dr
fauci was very clear about this on
sunday on four sunday shows let me just
note
is that these are not we now have three
vaccines
that are safe that are effective in
preventing serious illness
effective in preventing death and anyone
in the country
uh who has access to any of these
vaccines should take them
but it's certainly something that we are
aware of in terms of that concern and we
are going to continue to communicate
broadly and through a range of channels
how effective all of these vaccines are
go ahead thanks jen a couple questions
on new york and then
one on russia um you know obviously
this this third allegation against
governor cuomo has come out this woman
did work for
president biden uh during the campaign
i'm wondering what the president thinks
about the calls for governor cuomo to
resign
and whether he's spoken directly either
to his former staffer or the governor
about this situation
uh the president believes as i've noted
that
every woman who comes forward should
deserves to be heard and treated uh
you know we're giving this i get that
there's certain things she can't say
but it would be nice to hear something
other than the same canned answer
subpoena power and we certainly support
that moving forward
in terms of any other conversations i
did not work on the campaign as you know
i know that she did work on the campaign
i believe she was an organizer in
southwest florida i don't know if they
had i'm not a it might be
rather than just repeating that she
could say at this time
the president is not prejudging anything
wants the investigation to go forward
and has not made a call one way or the
other on resignation
if that changes we will let you know no
governor cuomo is also facing questions
over the nursing home situation
they do keep answering this asking the
same questions that's fair
he came up here to the white house in
that capacity to discuss coded with the
president his top aide melissa de rosa
who's been
pretty embroiled in this nursing home
situation was also
advising the administration on top until
the response during the transition
does the president believe he should
step aside from the nga and are you
still
you know seeking advice from his
administration on code
well that's a decision for the nga not a
decision for the president or the white
house
but i would say that new york as you
know continues to be one of the hardest
hit states
by the covet pandemic it is one of the
hardest hit states by the
resulting economic downturn and of
course we're going to continue to work
with
officials in that state to help the
people of new york help get the pandemic
under control
and help get people back to work and
just uh
going back to russia you know as michael
was pointing out we're now
i believe right in the midst of the
seventh anniversary of the crimea crisis
um and we have seen you know similar
sanctions before against
the putin regime i'm wondering if you're
considering anything
you know what's the next step what could
be beyond sanctions and also as this
discussion is happening
is the administration factoring in the
captive americans paul whelan and trevor
reed
in their response to this and in
potential future actions well of course
we raise the fact that american citizens
are held
uh by the russians at every opportunity
um
and at every level uh i would say that
as i noted earlier
the review is still on ongoing underway
of several actions concerning actions
including
it's like you can pre-write these
answers she says what they're doing on
russia reporter asks
are they going to do more of course the
press secretary is going to say
i don't have anything else to announce
and we're not taking anything off the
table
and we'll continue to evaluate the
situation like it's just it's a game
and a time and manner of their choosing
certainly sanctions is part of that
uh but they reserve the right to respond
in a manner seen an
unseen uh policy once that process is
concluded
thank you very much sure go ahead thank
you ma'am um
one question for me and then two from my
colleagues who can't be in the room okay
um first off something that sort of
touches i guess on immigration and then
also on on vaccines
uh we're five weeks into the new
administration and the president hasn't
named a permanent fda commissioner and
then yesterday we heard from the dhs
secretary
who said that he's trying to rebuild an
agency dismantled by the previous
administration
but so far the president hasn't named a
nominee for director of immigration
and customs enforcement a commissioner
of u.s customs and border protection
a director of u.s citizenship and
immigration services
what's taking so long you're right and
he's eager to
nominate individuals to fill all of
those spots we need to find
the right people and the right nominees
and hopefully we'll have news on that in
the coming weeks but i don't have
anything to
preview for you unfortunately on
personnel all right very good and then
from christian daytock of the daily
caller
interior announced yesterday it's giving
out more than 260 million dollars in
grants to help coal production states
create green energy jobs
is the white house launching any
programs to help those states transition
fossil fuel workers into green tech
where are they leaving that up to the
governors i'm not familiar with the
interior program i'm happy to certainly
check on that as i've noted in here
before
the president is committed to moving
forward on the rest of his build back
better agenda we're going to wait until
we're through the american rescue plan
and
that is signed into law direct checks
are going out to the american people
more money to get vaccines into arms
schools are starting to reopen with
money so
that's our focus now but he believes
that we can invest in areas like
infrastructure and do that in a way that
creates good paying green jobs
that are good paying union jobs and so i
have nothing
more to preview other than that remains
his commitment similar question
uh or uh similar agenda issue type
question from
ella nielsen of vox um she's wondering
where house democrats anti-corruption
voting rights bill hr
one falls on the administration's list
of priorities
well it is certainly i believe we put
out a statement of administration policy
yesterday um if not it's coming soon
so um but i believe we put it out
yesterday um
and uh the administration the president
remains committed to protecting
the fundamental right to vote and making
it easy for all eligible americans to
vote
that's something he talked about on the
campaign trail and uh
he that's why we need to pass reforms
like hr1
uh the for the people act and restore
the fighting voting rights act and so
it is a priority to the president
something he'll be working with
members of congress to move off move
forward on
quick follow-up good my question
yesterday okay so the virtual visitor
logs
sure you released the names of the
democrats
uh democratic senators who who were
speaking with the president virtually
is there any discussion about making
that standard operating procedure
as in he has a virtual meeting you
release the names or
should we expect to ask you each time
there's a meeting
we proactively most of the i can't even
think of a meeting we haven't but we
have
we plan to proactively release as we did
yesterday i think
when i said that it was released while i
was up here which is sort of a magical
moment but
i didn't really have anything to do with
that we were intending to release the
names
we will release the names of members
that he meets with
uh certainly we believe in being
transparent and making that available to
all of you of course today it's a
meeting with the caucus so that is
whoever attends that i don't have that
list you'd have to talk to the
leadership about that go ahead oh thank
you
so this is a little phone a friend on
the on the first lady's
uh trip that i can give more details on
hi owen jensen ewtn global catholic oh
no it's the religious guy
he sometimes asks weaponized questions
right now very concerned about the uh
the phrase pregnancy discrimination in
the equality doctor here we go
that it would force doctors to perform
abortions even if it
violates their conscience here we go
there are also concerns the bill would
force doctors to perform gender
transition surgeries
force and sterilizations again even if
it violates their conscience what does
the president president biden say about
those concerns
the president's been a long supporter of
roe v wade
it has been his consistent belief that
should be law and he
will fight to continue to protect that
as being law conscious concerns is
that a concern of his i think again i'm
just going to state what the president's
policies are did you have another
question
will president biden keep the conscience
and religious freedom division
at hhs the office that was put in place
under president trump
but keep it in place to receive
conscience complaints i hope not
what a dumb officer talk to a future
secretary becerra once he has confirmed
quickly another subject on education
every day that goes by some some kids
are in school year round have been for
example in nebraska kids have been in
school since day one back in august
in other states strictly virtually the
education gap
is widening no doubt about that when
fall rolls around if some schools are
still not in person
full time will the president accept that
or will he have a firm deadline in mind
to get kids back his goal is in the next
hundred days president wants schools to
be back in the classroom his wife is a
teacher
he believes that not only do students
want to be in school but teachers want
to be in school and he wants them to be
open
five every one of that guy's questions i
find super annoying we see guidelines
that were put out we now have a
secretary of education as of just yet
the goal is to be open in the next
hundred days if they're not open in the
fall
would the president see it as acceptable
come on dude firm deadline in mind for
when kids should be back i know he can't
demand it he can't do that i realize
it's up to school districts but
certainly he can create a sense of
urgency right well one of the steps that
you could certainly advocate for
is the pa or any of these folks could
advocate for is the signing of the
american rescue plan which has
160 billion dollars in it to help ensure
schools can make the
changes to their facilities can hire
enough teachers uh so that they can have
socially distant kids in classrooms so
that they can have enough bus drivers
and
that's an important component of getting
this done as well go ahead thank you jen
i have two questions the first one i
just want to go back on this concept of
vaccination vaccine
diplomacy this is our friend from quebec
that china
and russia by the tens of millions are
giving vaccine to african and south
american countries
we understand because you repeat this
every day that the president wants first
every american to be vaccinated
but at what point at what moment
aren't you worried that the u.s are
going to be left far
behind and russia and china will have
got
made major success uh successes with
these countries
well let me first say that we've also
made a major contribution to kovacs
which
is an international body coordinating
equitable fair distribution of vaccines
across the country that is the across
the world i should say i'm sorry
that is the mechanism and the body that
we feel this should be done
through they also ensure that these
vaccines that reach the standards and
meet the standards that we would fully
expect them to meet of course we're
concerned by russia
and china using vaccines to
engage with countries in a way where uh
they're not holding them
at times to the same standard the united
states and a number of other countries
would hold them to on human rights on uh
freedom of speech freedom of religion uh
freedom of media even of course that's a
concern
but the president's focus is on ensuring
the american people are vaccinated
uh once we are and of course we look
forward to engaging with and continuing
to engage with and contributing to
uh the global community's effort to do
that but our first priority is
vaccinating the american people
and my second question is on um fbi
director chris ray
in congress today uh acknowledged
recognized said that
what happened on january 6 at the
capitol
was domestic terrorism it sounds like
the review is done the review you talked
about a month ago you know remember
canada i do remember but the president
also called it domestic terrorism
on january 6th so he agrees the review
is not concluded
that's a 100-day review they're looking
at not just one incident but many
incidents
they want to do it comprehensively not
through a political lens
and when that's concluded i'm sure we'll
have more to say so you wouldn't you're
not ready yet to say just like canada a
month ago that
the proud boy is a proud boy
i i think that we're going to conclude
the review uh we're
looking at uh organizations white
supremacist organizations
a range of organizations across the
country and their impact
we're not looking at individual
incidents on their own it's important
that it's a comprehensive review
when that review is concluded we'll have
more to say
go ahead thank you two vaccine questions
and uh one from someone who's not in the
room because of
all of the social distancing on the
vaccine questions if there are
state local governments hospital systems
who are having real problems with their
websites
and their implementation of vaccine
registration systems
is the federal government offering
assistance uh
technical contractor support maybe using
the defense production act to require
a federal contractor in the technology
space to help them out
is there what's being done to help sort
of fix some of these technical
challenges that uh
state and local governments are having
it's an interesting question i'm
not aware of our engagement on it
support directly i think which is what
you're asking about with state and local
governments um
obviously it's i'm sure there's a lot of
traffic in certain places and that may
have an impact i can see if there's more
we can convey on that
and uh following up somewhat to a
question from a little bit earlier
if there are areas where it
seems like uh a governor
may be giving preferential treatment say
to an area where there are more people
who vote for one political party or
florida
in terms of the allocation desantis of
the vaccines and the location of sites
is there anything that the federal
government
can do directly to sort of steer more
vaccine doses
to locations where the governor may not
be allocating them
well one of the things we saw when we
went to the pfizer facility and this is
true for every vaccine is that they're
tracked we know where they go
and we certainly know if vaccines are
going more heavily to
one part or one demographic over another
and that would certainly be a concern
it would be something we would raise
directly with leaders in that state but
it is something that we watch closely
are there any examples where that has
happened or would that be something you
would
at this point keep under wraps if it had
happened i think
i'm not aware of specific incidents but
it is something we track and we watch
closely and i think our first step in
those scenarios would be to raise it
directly with leadership
in the states and the question i got
from someone who's actually in in
california
who is asking whether or not not a
reporter just someone in california
president plans on engaging
in the uh recall and in support of
the governor in the event that the there
is a recall election
uh in the california gubernatorial uh
race uh we've expressed support for the
governor
um but i don't have any other plans uh
on
related to the president to preview for
you kristen do you have another
question about dr seuss dr
seuss
obama and trump mentioned dr seuss in
their
read across america day proclamations
but president biden did not why not
well first the proclamation was written
by the department of education
and you could certainly speak to them
about more specifics about the drafting
of it but
read across america day which as you're
right has not existed forever has only
been
around for a short period of time
elevates and celebrates
a love of reading among our nation's
youngest leaders fox news now now cares
about literature celebrate diverse
authors whose work and lived experience
reflect the diversity of our country and
that's
certainly what they uh what they
attempted to do or hope to do
uh this year the full list of books
trump has read have been banned
nothing is banned it's especially
important that we ensure
all children can see themselves
represented and celebrated celebrated in
the books she's not a fox reporter but
does the omission have anything to do
with the controversy maybe she is i
don't know who this is
of diverse characters in the author's
books
well again i think uh it is important uh
that uh children of of all backgrounds
see themselves
in the children's books that they read
but i would point you to the department
of education for any more
details on the writing of the
proclamation go ahead
did the president have any reaction to
the passing of vernon jordan
i expect we'll have a statement out
shortly um even maybe as we speak but
shortly about his passing
yeah go ahead a little bit of news on
the media front
um your predecessor kaylee mcanenny has
just signed on as a fox news contributor
i'm wondering if you have any good
wishes for her advice and who
cares sure
i've done i've done fox news sunday
twice now i'm happy to go on
a range of shows uh i will say that i
knew kaylee a little bit not well
i met her when we were both cnn
contributors
and we did a few shows i'm not sure how
many together
like many americans we disagree on
political issues but we talked about
our families our spouses sports all
sorts of things in the green room
uh and i certainly wish her the best in
her future endeavors
thank you everyone all right
joe biden's white house press secretary
jenn saki
asked and answering a number of
different questions
many interesting many not so interesting
quite frankly
oh wait hold on oh sorry i just want to
give you more details about them
the first ladies i actually woke up this
morning and said i want to talk about
this and then i didn't do it so
um so as you all know when we've talked
about the senate confirmed the
president's secretary of education
miguel cardona fellow nut maker
go connecticut uh in a wide bipartisan
vote of 64-33
he will be sworn in by the vice
president this evening
tomorrow the first lady and secretary
cardona will travel to his hometown of
meridian connecticut
and to waterford pennsylvania to tour
k-38 public schools
that are open for in-person learning so
as mary asked about earlier
they're both lifelong educators they
will highlight the key cdc mitigation
strategies that the schools have
implemented successfully
in these locations listen to the
challenges they are facing due to the
pandemic
including the academic social and
emotional needs of students
highlight the additional resources in
the american rescue plan needed for
schools to open
remain open remain open and address the
needs of students and thank
educators for their work in supporting
students and their families
as i noted this is the top priority
reopening schools for secretary cardona
and i will expect you'll learn more soon
on who will be running point on that in
the department of education as well
so thank you everyone have a good
afternoon
what do you say puppies are oh yo
i see i from from stanford so you know
they're not the same debate there better
bagels and sandwiches though in the
northeast
wow and maybe she will soon take a
position on an everything bagel do you
want
everything on the the seeds on the top
and
bottom sometimes called an everywhere
bagel
or only on the top certainly the
everywhere uh
bagel less traditional but i like it i
want seeds on the top and bottom
otherwise i will just eat only the tops
only the tops leaving the bottoms for
other people which is quite a move all
right everybody thanks for joining me
i'll be back again very soon big big day
not going to stick around too much
longer today but
may even be back later may even be back
later for the biden event thank you